okay hello everyone it's Michael BOS
from orderflows decom and today I'm
going to talk about one way orderflow
will improve your trading and I'm going
to show you in today's market analysis
for Tuesday March 21st 2017 you know it
was interesting today in the equities it
was uh up and then it was just down down
down down couple bounces up and but
mostly down it's big down day and but
there was something in a non-equity
market that was very very telling and
again you know it's one thing to talk
about order flow but when I show you
it's just going to you know hopefully it
can open your eyes to the value of order
flow and you know before I jump in a
brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any type of investment
decision Futures training contains
substantial risk and is not for every
investor an investor could potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing one's
Financial Security or lifestyle only
risk r capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
there's a reason why you have a
disclaimer like this because you know
people come into trading and they think
it's uh the answer to their money
problems when you know trading is a
skill you have to take time and you have
to learn it you know if if you don't
learn it you can't just all of a sudden
sit down in front of a screen and start
uh punching orders into the system
thinking going to make money you know
some people will I mean you could get a
bunch of monkeys in a room and give them
a bunch of typewriters and sooner or
later someone's going to produce a uh
coherent Shakespeare novel but um you
know in general you know trading takes
time to learn and you know order flow
helps you understand the
market okay so this is a soybean chart
okay wow people say soybeans big
deal you know soybeans uh you know it's
not a glamorous contract it's not the uh
you know it's it's not the crude oil
it's not the bonds it's not the e- mini
snps but you know a lot of people have
made a lot of money trading beans um you
know you just you know people don't want
to admit it but it's actually a great
contract for trading and if you're
looking at this you know you say yeah
yeah it' be nice to have been able to
buy down here um you know you got a nice
Rally from basically 9.98 did come back
here test these lows it held and rallied
back up I mean you know if you could
have a reason to be buying down in here
you know and down in here wouldn't you
want to know and if you're just looking
at this chart you know yeah I mean I
know Candlestick guys will say oh you
know it's so obvious you had a hammer
down here a pin bar you know whatever
they're calling it nowadays um you you
could have bought it you know what about
here this was the low at this time you
know it didn't hold it still made new
lows you know from 9 um you know this
low is 997 got the way down to 9.95 so
you would have been stopped out there
you would have been stopped out here so
you know it's one of those things you
know when when it works people say yeah
it's so obvious you should have bought
down here on on the Candlestick chart
but then you know then they're
forgetting about this one here um so I'm
going to show you with with order flows
you know today it just really stood out
um this low that it was just like the
standout trade of the day you know even
though equities were all over the place
you know and and I I get uh I get emails
from other people that run trading room
saying oh you know we had a 30o day
today it was great but um you know I
like things that are a bit more solid
that I could put my hand on okay so this
is the order flow chart in the soybeans
at that time at the low and what do you
see at this low okay so you know this
was the first um hammer that failed okay
then you had the one down here you got a
few things going on down here I mean
look at this volume 1084 105
1072 that is solid I mean even in this
bar here 1022 this is all solid support
from the institutional level um you know
if you follow beans at all you you know
that size above 500 is I say rare but
you know it does happen um and here
you've got you know three price levels
in this bar even this one 400 is quite
big um you know and even in this
previous bar a th000 you know this
information is only there on a on a
footprint chart he said if you're
looking at the bar chart like I just
showed you it's not there so you know
you have very solid support down here
and this is you know between 995 and um
996 so at this 996 95 level you've got
1,000 2,000
3,000 um you know 4,000 plus you know
another 400 here just trading on the bid
that people are bidding there I'm not
even talking about what's trading on the
offer at this point really what's
getting my attention is this the size
that's being traded on the bid so you
you have a big big buyer or you know
several big buyers all defending this
level for whatever reason and then you
know the market did rally up rally rally
rally starts coming back down get back
down here 9952 you see the buying yeah
it doesn't get through that level it's
still
holding even down here you got this
selling IM balance right here at the low
point of control on this bar right at
the
low and then it's just know just
straight up straight up straight up all
the way you know all the way up to the
highs of the day you know so I mean that
was you know we're only at uh let's just
start at 10:03 you know just straight up
you know aggressive to buying all these
Deltas all
positive you know this was and then you
got up here you know then you start you
know it starts changing up here negative
Deltas but from um you know
996 all the way up to 108 what is that
96 108 it's 12 cents you you know one
cent move in the soybeans is $50 so
that's uh $600 move there um you know
that that was I'm not saying you would
sold it up at 10:08 you know I mean say
you only you sell it at 10:06 or
something you know at least a 10-cent
move um you know but that was that was
the you that was very glaring there I
mean that's not something you see all
the time but again it's only information
you're going to see if you're looking at
a footprint chart again you know if if
you're looking at this bar chart you're
not going to see it in there you'll see
oh you got a hammer here yeah you also
had a hammer here yes some hammers uh I
wouldn't say you had them up here but
you know definitely you had one here
right that failed stopped you out but
this one you know was very very obvious
in the footprint
chart next up is the uh snps I honestly
I wasn't going
[Music]
to do a video today but um you know
someone messaged me and said hey you
know what let's talk about the snps okay
so I I remember early in the room today
um you know we had we had made these
highs this morning um you know just
after the cash open you know there's a
Divergence up there um I wasn't a big
fan of this Divergence but we did sell
off from the high down into the lows you
the one thing that I I was looking at
yeah I wasn't necessarily convinced that
we're going to have such a big down day
honestly um but one thing I did notice a
little bit late you know I say late but
you know
9:30ish is these point of controls
really starting to migrate lower you
know earlier you had the point of
control up here then you got another
point of control down here here and then
down here and then down here so you you
you you're getting lower points of
controls um you know throughout the
morning and you're just coming down you
know it's all negative
Deltas it it wasn't as clear I mean I
kept going I at first I was I was really
keying in on the on the three range
chart I mean you see on a day you know
people one of the questions came up you
know what's the value of the volume
profile well on a day that's
trending okay look for on a day that's
trending down look for lower points of
controls forming and you're getting them
you know you had this one here then you
got this forming in here then you got
this one here then you got this one um
and again I didn't expect it to go as as
low as this and get you know this this
other big profile down here um you know
I I I realistically I was looking for
somewhere down into the 50s not all the
way down into the 30s but um you know
this was something that was giving it
away the lower points of control on a
market that's trending on on a trending
day that's what you're going to get
you're get lower points of control on a
trending day down on a trending day up
you're going get higher points of
control and you know we could talk about
the ratios you know here it was a
Divergence you want they went from a
Divergence sell at the high of the day
to to this Divergence here did pop up a
little bit started coming back down um
you got another Divergence here um you
know again I'm not a big fan of just
trading divergences by themselves and
but again you know the other thing that
I like to point out you know this is a
10 range chart um on the three range
chart between
930 and 950 you had like six failed
divergences when you start getting in a
short period of time when you get failed
divergences like here this is on the 10
range chart got it at 958 106 1011 you
get three failed divergences in quick
secession so you're making new lows and
on trending days you're going to have
repeated failed Divergence
okay and you know just just that that's
what happens on Trend days so when you
see them on days like this you know you
could
be um very hesitant to take Longs in
this case on the way down you know
buying divergences be very careful okay
now if it's a trending day up and you're
getting a lot of failed divergences to
the upside which you saw in the last
couple weeks when when we were rallying
all that time you're getting a lot of
failed divergences on the upside but
when you get them you know happening in
pretty quick you know one after the
other so to speak you know here's 958
10:06 1011 you've already got three in
what is that 13 minutes that's not a
good sign for the market that it's going
to be
rallying and even look at this I mean
the other point is you had one I mean
look at all this negative Delta 3,000
1300 4,000 4,000 4,000 yeah positive
Delta 36 okay fair enough it you got a
little bit of a bounce and then um you
know how is it again it's
allus 2,000 - 400 you know 1500 okay
it's not getting stronger keep going
lower and every time you get a positive
Delta it's weaker um 1500 still 12,000
or 12, 1200 negative Delta 300 so you
went from your first one 3,000 first
time you hit this Divergence you had
some decent buying come in 3,000 second
time new low new Divergence 1,500 so
it's getting weaker uh the third time
Divergence 300 so you can see the buying
is actually even though you're hitting
these lows you're getting you know the
buying is is weakening a little bit but
you're still getting the the strong
negative Deltas 2,200
1900 you know then it picks up again uh
4, 2900
1300 and here
um again you see these blue lines like
this is these are some of the indicators
I won't get into that here um yeah again
it's just you know it's just under
pressure all day I mean every time you
get a little bit of start to string
together a couple positive Deltas you
just get whacked with some very strong
negative Deltas again um but you know
it's not until you know sort of later in
the day you know you get this Divergence
here get a ratio again if I'm looking to
get long off of a Divergence I I want to
have a ratio in the order
flow and I want to have it relatively
soon here's not a
Divergence you this was a bit
interesting I remember looking at this
you know coming down here the Delta is
getting weaker 1,00 600 181 on the low
so it's still negative but you know this
Delta is decreasing instead of getting
you know stronger it's getting a little
bit it's lightening up so - 2 - 1900 -
600 - 180 and then boom positive um 2200
2100 you know so it's strong in here um
you know and and you get a nice little
rally here you know from the 23
50 Area you know all the way up to the
you know the 54
area you know further keeps going up but
still I mean you know you would have
been if you a day it was such a big down
day you know you got to be careful of
trying to buy it because you know any
bounces that you get you know if it's a
strong trending day down any bounces
that you get are going to be shortlived
you know don't don't don't think you're
going to get a 10o bounce off a low
where there's just immense selling going
on um you know you'll get a little bit
of a bounce but not much
um you know and you just have you know
other divergences so here you have a
Divergence and you got a ratio
afterwards you know a ratio that I like
you got one two coming in again you're
getting some strong Deltas here well
this is a 400 but this one's strong
22,400
2,900 um you know 3,000 really at this
point I was looking at this and this is
a 10 range chart and this gives you an
idea how fast this Market's moving you
know 1 minute between these two bars 2
minutes between this this one is 8
minutes um yeah I was expecting more of
a bounce a little quicker um it took a
little bit of a while to get up to here
um so you know this is from you know 45
A2 area up to the you know almost the 50
Area it's like 49 um before it starts to
sort of Peter out again um and then just
sort of go sideways and you get that
that late uh sell off going down into
the close I mean we're under so much
pressure today I didn't expect to see us
get any sort of rally going into the
close you know I mean everybody
was had very negative outlook on the
market um yeah I'll just I'll pull up
the uh the three range real quick
because you know on the three range I
remember talking about this in in the
room this morning I was a little bit
late to the party and I'm picking this
up
actually but just going back
here I think it was around
here
it was this or what time was
that somewhere in here um well there was
a couple things okay so first talk about
this this was 916 you have a Divergence
here
okay one Divergence here so I I was
looking at this three range so it's 916
the first one 925 second one here
another Divergence that
fails um
927 So within 10 minutes 11 minutes you
so far had three failed divergences
which to me is usually a sign um you
know pay
attention if we make new lows we go
lower here you know I don't want to say
three is is the number but you know what
after three it's really got my attention
that you know it's probably going to
start failing then here you get one
fails so new low here you got another
Divergence so 928 so from 9:16 to 928
you got four already so you know at that
point it's like hey stick a four this
Market it's going lower it's
done and you're taking out the lows with
you know selling imbalances again which
is a sign that we're going to go lower
you so at
9:30 you got another
Divergence at this price it's 23 61 and
a qu again you we do rally up here from
61 and a qu all the way up to 64 and A4
um you just sort of go sideways hanging
around and it's not you know that's at
what time is that 9:30 it takes from 9
30 I I I was looking at I didn't realize
that those failed divergences cuz I was
I I was talking about some other
stuff but um you by the time I realized
it was around 940 or something it's a
bit long for me to you know 20 minutes
it's not till 953 that you start making
these new lows
here and once you do that
955 you know we're trading 57 um you
know on the volume profile you know it's
hard to see here cuz you got such a big
volume down there but um you know on the
we had put in this new level here I was
looking for a new level to be forming
down in here I mean we got through this
level and actually put it in a bit lower
than I was expecting I was expecting
around the 58 59 level um you know but
we started putting in that volume down
here at 55 and a quarter you know at
that time 20,000 on this profile was all
those other point of controls were
around the 20,000
area and then we know we just continued
to sell off there um but but the sign
was there between 916 and 930 where you
got basically four um failed
divergences in quick seccession you you
didn't on the 10 range chart it took a
bit longer to form but you know on the
three range chart it was a bit clearer
there and the lower points of control
were very clear so you know it was you
know those were you know those were some
of the signs early in the day you know
by by 9:30 on you know what sort of day
you could be looking at the other
thing that I want to talk about again
you it's uh yeah know it's
something you know I mean the beauty of
orderflow right is you got all this
information on your charts that you know
nobody else is is seeing because they're
just looking at bar
charts and you know something that's
that's quite important here is this are
these stacked
imbalances and I I talk about this um
you know before many times I even did a
video on it and it's what I call it is
these overlapping stacked imbalances why
is it overlapping well you know I see a
stacked in Balance I draw out a zone
right it's five bars 1 2 3 4 5 I expect
the the market to move within these five
bars I don't look for a stacked
imbalance to hold all day um you know
some people do I think it's
wrong you know they'll look for it to
come back up in there okay fair enough
you know each every person has their own
way of interpreting order flow um this
is how I interpret it but when I have an
what I call an overlapping right so I've
got this stack buying IM balance and my
zone is here goes out five bars if
Within These five bars either above or
below in this case is below I get an
opposite stacked imbalance in this case
I got stacked imbalance below this Zone
to me that's very bearish you know it
doesn't matter that it's below I could
have you know the market could be
starting to Rally then I get up here I
got a stack selling in Balance I would
treat the same go with this go with the
second imbalance when you have an
opposing imbalance right you have the
buying imbalance and you got to selling
imbalance Within These five bars that's
usually that's a high percentage trade
very high percentage and what the market
do Bo you know we just sold off you know
within within minutes you know we're
trading all of a sudden you know we're
trading from 67 next thing you know
we're trading all the way down at 63 64
63 and a half down here um 63 and a half
64 um you know and you know that's
from you what time is this
925 you know within to 927 you know
that's 2 and a half minutes that you
just sold off you know four points and
I'm not even talking about you know the
rest of this moved on but that was
something that was also very
um very convincing early in the order
flow again it's um you know if you're
not using order flow you're missing out
on this information and it's it's really
valuable information again you know I
mean if if there's only I I said at the
beginning of this video if there was one
thing you could take away from the order
flow right
was was you I was talking about this uh
soing chart here after the open at uh 8
something
uh where was it here it was this one
down here you know no sorry 9:00 you
know all this volume I mean if that was
you know when I created this video this
is one thing that I really wanted to
talk about you know is if there was one
thing you could take away from orderflow
it's this you know looking at the volume
using your head you know everyone wants
to computerize everything and make
everything
automatic you know and yeah this could
probably be automated um into some sort
of trading algo
but you know the best Traders are people
that think for themselves right not
necessarily rely on any indicator
because you start IND you start uh
programming the stuff in there then you
know it's going to show up you know how
you going to Define it I mean I know how
to define it but it's just easier to
look at it and use the computer on your
head right I mean it doesn't take any
special skills or anything to sit there
and say hey you know what 1,00 1,000
1,000 that's big numbers to be appearing
there in the soybeans especially at the
low so you know that the Market's being
defended and you can see it traded from
this low straight up to the highs um
without much um
you know without much resistance I mean
yeah it came off a little bit here
that's it I mean you know started going
sideways here sorry didn't trade up to
this High take that back oh we did test
the low again here you know um but this
again this was another sign so say you
missed the first part and you're just
showing up here at 10 you know 10:30
again this is very bullish you know then
again you know this is the Delta scalper
but that's another story this here is
very bullish as well so
it did give you another chance to get
into this
market and you know the other thing I
talk about you know that you know I said
one way so I'm actually talking about
two ways is is the imbalances looking at
the
imbalances you know this information is
is there is available it's not like some
secret information that they're hiding
from you you just have to have the right
software that
analyzes the order flow that's coming
into the market simple
so you know the next thing that I want
to talk about real quick is uh you know
one or two indicators okay so this
indicator this is the volto transition
it's an indicator um just going to show
you some
you no no signals earlier you know I
opened my charts this morning in here so
it reads the order flow as it comes in
so it's not going to show up on on past
charts um but this morning again you
know pretty uneventful morning in the
Dow I'm just sitting there watching it
uh got a Buy Signal here okay you know
this day was a very volatile day um you
know it started to work out uh then came
back down and Market sold off so you
know this one you know that would have
stopped you out okay and I'm showing it
to you showing it to you full disclosure
I don't want you to see that oh you know
there was a trade you only showing the
winners okay so you had the one trade
you know first one was a loser then look
at this a nice uh sell here right at you
know what you want to call it you know
840 it just Dro drop drop and the
700s get a buy Here shortlived rallied
up before selling off don't know if you
know so from 840 down to you know the
the 800 area uh this buy didn't work out
got a short buy Here could got something
out of it a little sorry short sell here
a little sell came off you know a little
buy here got something you know maybe
could have got something out of it
before it sold off if you're trailing
your stop you know Trail your
stops um there was no signal there um
this buy started to work out that would
have stopped you out so you know you had
you know one nice winner you've had
about two or three you know stopouts
okay fair
enough then here you get another sell
signal in here you know somewhere around
720 to 725
yeah it comes does come back up to 7:30
yeah I mean I don't know if you're
trailing your stop would have You' been
stopped out somewhere in here with a
small profit yeah maybe again you know
if if you're a little bit more generous
I mean if you're seeing how the
volatility you know how volatile this
day is already we sold off 100
points um you know you may approach it a
little bit different if you stayed in
your position you would have been
handsomely uh rewarded obviously if
you're short at
720 and you saw how this Market sold off
quite violently down into what's this
area down in here where you get a buy
signal again if you're trailing your
stop probably would have been stopped
out if not it'd probably still be in
that position to catch a little bit of a
rally um a little bit of you know little
sell here um this one I don't think you
would have taken because this bar
couldn't uh take out the the low of the
signal
bar um
this one yeah I don't think it would
have taken for the same reason this one
yeah you would have taken um and gotten
out in here when you got a Buy
Signal yeah I don't know depending on
where you're placing your stop in here
seeing how this Market is you know
already had a 300 Point range I don't
know if you'd be giving it you know five
ticks you might want to be giving it a
little bit more than that you you can
adjust your levels on more volatile days
I mean it's up to
you you but it's a move
from whatever 7:05 up to the 735 is
could have got something out of it then
later in the day you get a nice sell
signal in here you know again you 1 2 3
four this the fourth bar that you get
your sell in here again you know I I
like to let it take me into the market
at this point I'm not short I'm not
short I'm not short but this bar would
have gotten me short you know within you
know several bars it's got to start its
move if it doesn't it's it's probably
not going to make that move obviously so
again you know a move from 705 back down
to the 680s
this one didn't work out it would have
stopped you out this
one depending on where you put your stop
might have stopped you out uh then you
get another sell signal in here pretty
quick 670 that
area you know it just sort of takes you
back down in here you depending on where
you're trailing your stop out I don't
know where you would have gotten out um
this buy didn't work out that would have
stopped you out the cell probably would
stopped you out this one no reason to
take that
one same reason here no reason to take
it it's not doesn't start selling off
until how many bars later this one yeah
you definitely would have gotten in
could have got something out of this
move yeah and that was uh you then later
in the day here this one this one would
have got you in you would have trailed
your stop got out but then you got short
here nice sell signal you know if you're
trailing your stop really quick in here
you would stopped out here with a small
profit but if you again you're giving it
some leeway again you know you're
already talking a 300 Point range day
maybe you're going to give it a little
bit you know you're got a 300 Point
range day right you know you're going to
get a lot of movement so you might want
to you catch the big moves sometimes you
got to expand it out a little bit your
your stops so you might want instead of
trailing your stop so close behind you
know you might want to be looking at you
know a different level you know a level
above you know the bar where your enter
and if you did
that you know if if you were astute
enough to catch that hey you know what
we're on a very volatile day I should
widen out my my stops um a bit more you
know again you would have caught a nice
move from the 660 level you know down
into the 620s so you know there was
there were moves to be had today um in
this
market so you know thanks for watching
this video uh to learn more about the
trading software that I use in this
presentation and you know if you want to
learn more about orderflow visit my
website www. orderflows doccom and thank
you and I'll see you on the inside
bye-bye